From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
13. My name is John Bitmer and I'm here in Denmark, South Carolina with videographer John Bishop to interview Dr. Dr. Cleveland L. Sellers Jr and the President of Voorhees College.
This interview will become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, DC.
Dr. Sellers were delighted to be here today and we thank you for taking the time to talk with us.
Thank you, thank you.
I would like to start with your early childhood. You were born and raised right here in Denmark, weren't you?
Born and raised in Denmark, the irony is that it's been pretty much a complete circle for me and that I started out here as a mascot for the college in when I was three years old.
And I came back in 2008 as President of the college so it's a very interesting experience returning home.
What was it like growing up in Denmark? Tell us something about your childhood, your family?
Well, the first bit of information is that the college here was the center, a cultural center of an educational center for the community.
I actually went to high school on this campus, the state of South Carolina rather than building a high school for black students, paid for his tuition for each student.
So all the students in this area when they started eighth grade, ninth grade, tenth grade and 11th grade, I'm sorry, ninth grade, tenth grade, 11th and 12th, they would come to this campus.
And this campus was, this school was actually founded by a woman 23 years old who was a graduate of Tuskegee.
And so she used the Tuskegee model in terms of building educational institutions and came to Denmark to find, found her school.
She had a couple of the efforts in South Carolina but they were all two cases of Austin and one of Malphee's and so she ended up here in Denmark.
So the school is made under the Tuskegee Booker T. Washington Industrial Education Model.
So it is just that kind of philosophy was very prevalent here.
Even though you had the, the Du Bois influence also at Voorhees College, it was the kind of bill yourself up, educate yourself, have faith in your community and those kinds of ideals that grew out of Booker T. Washington.
So that was the kind of community I grew up in. It was segregated, I mean, rigidly segregated.
Race relations.
Race relations were as a segregated community in the South all throughout the South.
And that is separation in terms of schools, social activities, almost complete separation up and down the ranks.
There were no buses so we didn't have segregation on the buses.
But we did have in the theater even in terms of patronizing stores.
There were certain things that you had to buy without actually having an opportunity to use a dressing room and that kind of thing to see if it fit and that all of that kind of stuff.
What was the roughly the ratio of break down between black and white at the time?
Denmark has been majority black for a long period of time and it was majority black at that point.
But all of the official offices were held by whites, Superintendent of the School School Board.
I was in the economy back then. What were people doing for a living?
Back then there was a pretty busy kind of and a live and well economy.
We had three railroads that actually came through Denmark. That was a unique environment in which we kind of grew up in.
And there was a pickle plan, a furniture plan, a bowling, a cocoa, a bowling company and all those kinds of things.
When the railroads went away and when the economy reverted back to pretty much agricultural, rural agricultural economy, those jobs also went away.
And so you had a decreasing of the population since the period of desegregation.
Many whites moved out of the community.
The schools in Denmark actually integrated, desegregated around 1972.
So you're talking about some 18 years after brown. That was resistance to desegregation.
Did you see those students leave the schools when desegregation came or used to?
Yes, sir. Over the last 10 years it's been about 98, 99% African-American in the school.
Pretty typical in many areas.
But now the unique part about the Voorhees connection and the school connection was that there were a lot of cultural incentives and there were a lot of educational opportunities that were afforded students.
The teachers provide a certain respect for education and dignified education and also provide nurturing that built up these.
I guess values and principles, the importance of education, the importance of faith and the importance of service.
And so we learned that as we went along, we learned about the Harlem Renaissance and literature and art.
We learned about the importance of actually developing skills going out and returning something to the community that nurtured you and actually got you started.
Those kind of values were very important values for young African-Americans to have going out into this new world that was very soon become desegregated.
The other was that we also were able to tie into the black press and we were able to read about and understand what was going on in Montgomery.
You could discuss that in school, Emmett Till.
What talk about that a minute?
You were, I think, 11 years old when Emmett Till was murdered in Mississippi.
What kind of impact does that have on you?
And I want to talk about your folks too.
Yeah, well, I was devastated by the fact that Emmett could have been me or any other black kid around that same age.
And so I related to that very quickly.
And we had discussions in our class about Emmett Till.
I had a cover of the jet, took it to school, some other students had the same thing.
And so we had rational discussions about it.
And the question comes up, how do you address that?
And I think for us, it was projected out that that would be our destiny to try to find remedies to a society that would allow that to happen.
It would condone that and would actually free those who were responsible for that murder.
And I think that that was a way in which we actually got away from revenge and hatred and those kinds of things.
We talked about how we were going to use Emmett Till to build on that we would rectify in our work and in our effort.
And the nasty that they tragedy that happened to Emmett Till.
It just was, I've become obvious to me that you had a unique opportunity here in school to do these things.
I mean, these kinds of discussions would not be going on in a specific class.
And people would be teachers who were fired for something like that.
Absolutely.
In this rural outpost.
That's right.
And when the independence of the British colonies in Africa was taking place, we could actually relate to that.
And some of the professors at the institution related to Kwame Nkrumah because he was a graduate and a student at Lincoln University.
So there was a kind of common thread here.
So with Patrice Lumumba and the Congo and Kwame Nkrumah and Jomal, Kinyata and Kenya.
Those kinds of discussions were very common place.
And we did have students here from Africa.
So they were able to actually bring news back through literature and dispatches in Africa.
And those things would show up in the campus news letter and newspaper that the students would actually put up.
And so it was that kind of nurturing and that kind of educational environment that we came up in.
Most of the students that graduated with me went on to college.
Some made a D2 and went to the home forces in order for them to get the GI bill so they could come back and go to school.
And we were talking about probably in some way in the neighborhood of 85, 87% of the students who graduated from me went on to some kind of company.
That's very high.
Tell us something about your books and your family.
My family, both natives of South Carolina, my mother comes from Abbeyville, South Carolina, which is up in the northern part of the state around Greenville and Anderson, South Carolina.
She was in a family of eight sisters.
And it was a large family. She lived on a large farm and they actually were farmers and they raised horses on that farm.
And other things, but that was their primary focus.
My father grew up in Denmark South Carolina and he graduated from high school in 1933.
Education was very important to him because he was in Denmark and education was very important to all young African Americans in this community.
He was an entrepreneur. He followed in the tradition and footsteps, the things that he had learned from the Book of T Washington influence at the school.
So he was a farmer. He was not not real at all, but a rent built in rented houses and property. He drove care of anything that he could find a way in which he could actually generate some revenue from.
He did that kind of thing. And the latest, the last thing major thing that he did was he built the motel. He understood the movement of people in and out and the need for the colleges that were here to do that kind of thing.
And so that's what he did.
My mother was an educator. She graduated from South Carolina State back, I think it was around the 20, 27, somewhere around that time.
And she then went on to Hampton University and she got her masters and was able to, she got it in nutrition and English.
And she was able to come back to South Carolina. She started at Voorhees College and worked here for about 20 years.
And then she moved over to the technical and trade school for the state of South Carolina, which was also located here in Denmark.
And she worked there for 15 years. And she had several years after graduating from South Carolina State teaching in high schools.
So she was an educator and she also was very much a community organ in it and actually ran for a number of years when I was a young, a, a, a center that was built in in Denmark by donations and contributions.
It's a Denmark Recreation Center. And she managed that all the way until she was much older and passed her retirement and she passed that off to another gentleman.
But so in that she was very, much concerned about working with young ladies and actually helping them kind of grow up and find their way and empower them to, to be,
to take advantage of whatever educational opportunities they were and be good at what they did. So that's, yeah, I have a sister Gwendolyn. She was a year old and I was.
I was born and my father was in the military in World War II. He was, he was stationed in France. And he was very proud of his, his work there.
He, he, he had a business, a kind of cafe restaurant business that he, he left to go to fight. And he was in the motor pool, I think in France.
And he went off and came back, met a lot of people, seemed to have created some good friendships as a result of his experience in France and that kind of thing.
And he came back to Denmark and, and continued. My sister was born a year before me and she kind of grew up also with, without father being out of, for two years in, in the military.
She went to school here to matriculate it through, went on and, and became a school teacher, master school teacher, a school counselor in New Jersey. And she was there for 30 years and had returned to, to South Carolina now.
Yes, was, was, uh, church very important in your family life?
Church was very important in my family life and, uh, I had, I was a schism. You know, we, my mother was a, uh, was an A.M.E. when she was born and reared and as she grew up.
And when she married my father, uh, he was a Baptist. So she then went to the Baptist Church. And when she came to work at Voorhees, Voorhees was affiliated with the Episcopal Church.
And, uh, she and my, my sister and I, all affiliated with the Episcopal Church. And so she was there for a minute.
And then, uh, in later in life after she retired, she went back to the A.M.E. Church. And so, uh, we remain in the Episcopal Church. We're, my sister and I, pretty, almost cradle Episcopalians.
And, um, and, uh, I have been affiliated with the Episcopal Church from that time until now. There was stints in which, um, you know, I was doing other kinds of things and didn't have the same kind of affiliation that I had before after.
But, uh, it has, it has been, even through the movement experience, uh, very much involved, uh, when I was at Howett at the Non-Valent Action Group, we used to meet at the, um, at the Episcopal Affiliated Youth Club, um, there at, at Howard University.
And through my experiences with SNCC, we had at various and Sunday times, support from Episcopal Priests all over the country and all over the South. So, it's been a good, mm-hmm.
We're back.
Okay.
Um, well, with this kind of background, it was naturally assumed, I think, that you were going to go to college, but the movement came along.
And in February of 1960, the city began in Greensboro, North Carolina.
And they, uh, spread to Denmark, South Carolina.
Absolutely.
Talk about that for a moment.
Well, um, I, again, I'm a high school student and I'm here. I actually work in the student center.
Um, I have my, um, my high school assistant principal, wife, runs the student center. So, she asked me if I'd work in and I do.
And it's on February, February 1, 1960, the, uh, city ends, occurring in Greensboro, North Carolina.
And the first night, it gets a blip on the news.
The second night, it has a more time because the news is actually talking about the students and, uh, the kind of, uh, tactics that were being employed and what was going to happen and all that kind of thing.
So the, the, uh, student center used to fill up every night for the nightly news to see what was going on in Greensboro.
And so students actually began to, to talk about the sit-ins and begin to, uh, talk about having meetings and then what are we going to do and how are we going to do that?
Uh, and so I had the opportunity because they were in the center usually and they would start meeting in the Senate and they would go to other places because they felt like they needed to be kind of out of the sight of the administration because nobody knew how the administration was going to accept this.
This was just a kind of, uh, students being really actively engaged in this process.
So they decided to, uh, to do a demonstration themselves and they actually were a boat, a boat with that.
They went to the president and asked the president, uh, because it's about two and a half, three, three miles downtown to the pharmacy if they could use the school bus in order for them to go to that.
And, uh, the president agreed, yes. And, uh, so then the, the, the D day came, I think it was the Thursday.
And the students were assembled and the president had been called by a number of the board of trustees who were local who said that they didn't think it was a good idea that he needed to not do the bus.
And they were scared to the students from coming downtown. They didn't know what was going to happen and they were concerned.
So, uh, he asked that the bus be withdrawn.
Uh, I think that, uh, I would agree that he was a lot like Warmoth T. Gibbs who was the president of, uh, of A and T at that time.
And his thing was was that I trust you and I trust your judgment to the students.
But I am not going to be able to, to be openly supportive of your actions.
So he told me that, you know, I, I cannot allow the bus to be used.
And that meant that the students had to march from the campus all the way down, which is the main thoroughfail and where he's rode.
So, downtown to another main thoroughfail to go to the, to the, to the drugstore that they were protesting at.
And it was a kind of, interesting kind of day. It looked like a very somber march.
And the students were single files about seven of them.
And they had only a Sunday best and they had on trench coats because it was kind of cool.
And they marched all the way downtown and went down and they were arrested at that point.
The, the priest from the school.
We're rolling.
So there, there was a certain people were arrested. Where were you in all this?
Well, I was, uh, first, let me just say that because nobody actually knew what the consequences of even unintended consequences were going to be.
The guys decided not to have any of the young ladies involved because they know that it was going to be some police brutality and arrest and all those kinds of things.
And they've used to allow any high school students to be involved.
Now, you could be involved in the planning and strategy and all that kind of thing.
So I was involved in, in the planning and the strategy and all that, but I couldn't be involved in the demonstrations.
There were arrested and the, um, the priest from the college actually goes down and, and get, retrieve them and bring them back to the campus.
I don't think charges will have a, a fix to that because that was never a trial or anything.
And I stayed actively involved with these students as they, they went to churches and, and other places that were known to be segregated in Denmark.
And we're a few, except into first Baptist church and a couple other churches and that kind of thing.
So we stayed active and we stayed connected to the other, um, groups that were engaged in protests, uh, doing that particular period of time.
And your autobiography, the river of no return, you write that your father was not too excited about your act.
Well, my activities began to accelerate.
And one of the things that I wanted to do was to put together an organization.
So, uh, I was thinking about a youth chapter of the NAACP.
And I began to, uh, organize a youth chapter of the NAACP.
And once we got it all organized and we got our cards and the college got its official charter.
Um, I wanted to have a rally that would just simply say to the community that there was a youth chapter of the NAACP in the city of Denmark.
At that point there was no NAACP chapter.
And when I did that, I invited, uh, one of the representatives out of, out of Atlanta, the come and speak for the rally.
I got to church, Rome, Baptist church and all of that kind of stuff.
And then, uh, I think it was the day of, of the day before.
Uh, my father said that, uh, I would have to reframe from being engaged in this activity and I could not go to the meeting.
How did you respond to that?
Oh, I was real upset because I had done a lot of the legwork and pulled people together and gotten people to commit themselves to going in.
All of a sudden he said that you would not even be there at the program.
I was, I was really upset and, um, and, and indicated that kind of upset and discuss with him.
But I did not go. I mean, I stayed, but I figured that it was time for me then to start looking for other places to be because I was, I had been bitten by this bug of, of Emmett Till and movement activities that were going on, et cetera.
So, um, I began to, to, to look at the possibilities of going to a, a private school and I wrote Stanton, uh, Staunton Military Academy up in, uh, up in Virginia.
And, uh, I sent the application in and all that kind of thing.
And where they had race, I didn't put anything.
And so they called me and asked me, um, what, what, that, you know, they were looking favorably at me and they said they saw that I did not put in race.
And they asked me if I was, was, was, was Negro.
And I said, yes. And they said, we'll sorry.
But, uh, we're not going to be able to accept you.
You thought you'd have a shot there.
I thought I was going to have a shot somewhere. I was just trying to get to an environment where I could kind of be my own person in regards to the movement.
And after that went by, I, I feed that I was going to do the rest of my time there.
And so I really got, uh, more involved with trying to tap in and support other, other movements.
One of those efforts was that we got the same group of young people that made up the youth in WACP.
And we went up to Rock Hill when the, um, the Freedom Riders had come through and then you had, uh, protest of that by what was then known as the Rock Hill 9.
And this was before you were in college.
Before I was in college here. And when I went up Charles Jones and Diane Nash and, uh, Ruby Dyer's Robinson had gotten arrested.
They had come in from, from Atlanta to, uh, protest the rest of the, uh, and so they, that's where the jail no bail kind of, uh, first time he was met these.
I didn't meet him. I went up, I went up to meet him and they were in jail.
And they had a session in which you could actually go out, but we went up early one morning.
We had the, the principles call, um, the priest call and my mother's car.
We had three cars and we took three cars full of students from here up there.
And I think that in that way we stayed connected, but I learned of Charles Jones and I learned of, of, um, Ruby Dyer's and, and Diane and, um, there was another person there and I can't remember who it was.
I just don't want to say somebody who had went, but there were four, uh, snickers who had come to that area to give that support and they went to jail and they talked about, uh, Ruby Dyer's talked about the fact that there, there was so much, uh, outpouring of support in that community and food.
And I think she said she gained about 11 pounds in the 30 days that she was out there. But anyhow, that's, that was another link and another connection.
And then I began to find in the state of South Carolina, there were other, uh, students that were becoming more active, militant, brown, down in Charleston was getting ready.
And the father was the head of the NAACP. They were getting ready to file a suit to desegate to schools in Charleston.
And, uh, a, uh, a, uh, uh, uh, a, attorney Matthew J. Perry Jr also was getting ready to file a suit on behalf of, um, of, um, uh, gant, hobby, gant at Clemson.
later the three students at the University of South Carolina.
So there was a lot of activity beginning to brew,
and we tried to tap into that to get that kind of support.
And then we off to Howard.
Yeah, talk about you.
A role in Howard in the fall of 62, I think.
Yes.
What kind of a school did you, what were you expecting
and what did you try?
Well, I expected Howard because it was considered
one of the larger HBCUs with a lot of history and tradition.
I expected it to be a hotbed.
You know, I'd come out of Voorhees
and there was a lot of activity and action
and a lot of students involved.
And you know, we come, I guess,
Booker T. Washington schools were considered
to be the kind of blue collar schools,
you know, the kind of laborers and workers
and those kind of schools.
And I didn't know that there was a kind of professional
white collar kind of bourgeois campus
like I discovered at Howard.
And so it was common for us to wear jeans to school.
And coming out of the South,
your hair was a little bit longer than the average
who had the skint down and all that other kind of hairdos.
And so that was a kind of contentious kind of relationship
that I have with Howard that people had some difficulty
with my way in jeans and Howard,
the young men wore pants, slacks and shirts.
And it was, if you were really very spiffy
and upbeat at lunch, you would change your shirt.
You wouldn't go back to class with the same shirt on.
So they were striving to become?
They were striving to become a part of the status quo.
And we were saying essentially that we need to be
opening that whole process up.
We don't need to be trying to be the token.
And so that's the way I felt that my experience
would be there, that I would be groomed to be open up.
Non-dialand action group name.
Yes.
Your activities there, what kinds of things
you're doing, who were you there?
Well, I was for a long time trying to find that niche.
And then I found maybe Mike Thelwell,
some of the others and they, and standing wise
and they told me about a meeting that they were having.
And I said, okay, well, I'll come to the meeting
and went to the meeting and there was a group of maybe
15 or 20, it grew after I joined.
And some of the others joined, it was Charlie Cobb
and a number of other folks.
Plus there was a, a SNCC office in Washington, DC.
And it would have, you know,
I have in Holdon, Olson and some of the other field staff
would be coming through periodically.
But what we were committed to was
learning more about the movement in the South
and trying to address issues
that needed to be addressed,
of communicating information.
Fun example, the whole issue about protection of voter rights
and civil rights workers in the South.
We ended up going to the Justice Department and picketing.
We ended up at the FBI and picketing.
We ended up at the White House and picketing.
That was our job and that was our role.
But we also had issues that were germane to DC.
Home rule was one of those issues.
The buses, I think it was run by a guy by name
with chalk as I remember it.
And desegregating of the buses
and the employment of black drivers and that kind of thing.
So we tried to mobilize the school
to respond to those kinds of things
and one of the things we recognized was that
you had to be in those critical places
at the school in order for you to be effective in communicating.
So we had people who went on the hilltop.
That was the newspaper, the student newspaper,
the Lycium program, the Student Government Association
and many of the organizations we wanted to have people
in field traded all those things
and actually began to have that kind of impact
and we began to try to target those kinds of things.
On the Lycium program, we started out trying to secure
the services of biode-rested
and the administration backed up
because biode was supposed to be a socialist
and we kept pushing and we kept pushing
and we kept pushing and we actually got biode there.
After these programs, we would have an opportunity
to have a kind of a one-on-one with whoever that speaker was
and we had a one-on-one with biode about tactics
and history and all those other kinds of things.
We recognized biode as being a good organizer
and we weren't about to try to take that away from him.
And so when you get around to the March on Washington
then biode reached back to get some of us
and some of the other snickers to work on the March
under the logistics couple of weeks before the March.
We were in DC and we had the responsibility
for all various and so-and-so kinds of logistics
moving people around, crowd, setting up the designated areas
for people to arrive and marshaling them
from the Washington monument down to the Lincoln Memorial.
Those kinds of things, even making the signs
and making the sandwiches.
So we had those assignments
and that was a unique opportunity and experience.
But before we even got there, we also decided
that once we were successful with biode
that we would go for Malcolm
and we were able to push the school on the Malcolm issue
and Malcolm actually came to the campus.
He had a wonderful presentation
though Auditorium was absolutely full
and after it was over we had an opportunity to talk
with Malcolm and-
The conversation was interesting because
that phase was like many kinds of things to say about
so we're right to move.
That's absolutely correct.
So you know we had that kind of debate
and we pushed all those kinds of issues.
And I think that one of the things that Malcolm used
to refer to-
I said the students of the movement,
that's how he referred to that whole group.
And we used to run into each other
and I'm talking about with the Snickers
in Washington frequently
and we would always stop and have that discussion
about what was going on.
Matter of fact when the March on Washington was going on,
Malcolm was in Washington and he called it
the Forest on Washington
and he talked about the big six and all that other kind of stuff.
For the only time he met King and Person I think was-
Yes, at the airport.
Yeah.
And they just kind of ran in each other
and wasn't playing anything.
The March, Biod Rustin was the principal organizer
and it was to be a protest march
but it really turned out that way.
No, it-
Talk about your feelings about.
You've done all this work, you've done all this organization,
you've got hundreds of thousands of people there.
Well, I think that for many of us,
even including the Snickers,
we were on the edge and it was a fledging kind of movement
of Snickers at this point.
We're still in an infestage even though we have been in Albany
and we've been in Danville
and we've been in a lot of other areas.
We were growing
and you had a small number of people
that involved in Snickers at that point
on a regular basis, on a full-time basis.
So we were using a lot of students
who would come doing the summer,
come doing a spring break or whenever it was.
And so we hadn't really gotten to the point
where we were talking about full-time organizers
working in any particular area.
So the March on Washington was one of those learning periods.
John Lewis speech, for an example.
The changing of that speech.
That was what was so controversial about it
that it needed to be changed.
Well, there was some objection,
one of the cardinals, Patrick O'Boyle, I think it's his name.
He was concerned that John used a language
that we would go through the South like Sherman
and burning the vestiges of segregation to the ground.
Wonderful metaphor.
I understand, but they said to Vowlin,
to you know, and this go create more.
And I think, you know, just Southern was just subjected
to that kind of terminology.
But the critical piece was that
A. Philip Randolph actually came to the Snickers
and said, you know, I've been working on this ever since 1940.
This is, and I'm close to having a dream fulfill.
Can you help me with this?
And I would really, really appreciate it
if you would make that.
And I think out of our, I guess,
commitment to a kind of person whose show as we were standing,
we said that we would actually make those changes
and not feel any guilt about that.
But I think that was also a critical point for the organization
because then we had to come to the conclusion
that we had to, if we had voice,
we had to be able to control it
and we had to be able to live up to it.
So after that, you didn't have people kind of coming in
saying, this is what you need,
and that's what you need and what you change your position
for the sake of me, anything else.
So we were very idealistic.
And so we thought that the March would have the kind of impact
that it may have.
And that is getting the message out about civil rights,
education, you know, health, welfare, those employment,
those kinds of things.
And we also saw that as the first real time
that on a national scale, you had the coalition
of civil rights, church, and kind of democratic liberalism
that would kind of come together for that particular thing.
And so there was a euphoria, I think, for many of us,
we were tired, exhausted, we worked very hard,
and there was a kind of euphoria.
And we were in the kind of ideal world in terms of now.
After Montgomery and after all the things
that had gone on, including mega-evils
and the students in Birmingham and the horses
and the dogs and the firehoses and all that kind of stuff,
that we had actually found a way to bring some kind of,
not closure, but bring some consolidation of all those things.
And the 16th Street Baptist Church Bombing kind of destroyed
all of that.
And so you're back to the real world.
And I think that at that point, you know,
eyes began to open up and we knew that we had to get back
to real business.
But we also, for many of us of the Emmett Teal generation,
recognize that we probably couldn't do this as part time.
And so we had to make some serious decisions
about going full time with civil rights
or leaving that to who could go full time
and get busy about our academics.
You couldn't do both.
So what did you drop out of that?
I was, I was, I was, I was, I was, I was, I was,
okay, we're back.
Okay.
So you were realizing that you were going to have to be full time.
When did you leave Howard?
Well, yeah, yeah.
We were assigned by Bob Moses,
we being nagged to be responsible for generating
and getting volunteers for the summer of 64.
And we also understood that we would be committing ourselves.
So all of Nag, probably 90% of Nag would go down.
But we had to recruit from the University of Maryland,
Morgan State, George Washington,
Joyce, American University.
Those schools in that Maryland DC cluster
would be the schools that we would actually recruit from.
And one of the unique parts about the recruitment
that we were doing is that most of the students
that we were recruiting were going to be African-Americans.
There were whites in there that actually went down
from that area.
But we would have the largest contingency
of African-American volunteers that we go down.
And so we kind of leveraged that to get
into the second congressional district of Mississippi,
which was the plantation area.
And that was the black belt of Mississippi.
And we felt like if we could get into those areas,
we could be much more effective in trying to get down in
and get these communities to kind of empower them
to organize and to put us out of our job,
put us out of work.
But I probably knew as soon as I made the commitment
to go to Mississippi, that would probably be it.
So I finished the semester at how it,
but most of that time, at the end of that semester,
I was in Cambridge, Maryland.
Talk about the Cambridge movement.
It became very violent with the lower
enrichances of the cleaning it.
Well, Cambridge, when we first went over,
was basically trying to organize the community
to have protests in that community.
And each time the protests ended up
in some kind of violent scuffle.
And at a point there, you had martial law in Cambridge.
And then the opposition in Cambridge invited in George C. Wallace.
We were in.
I was in Cambridge at that particular time.
And the National Guard was in charge,
eye along with Stokeley and Stanley Wise.
And Gloria were arrested and kept in a National Guard
armory overnight.
We were freed the next day.
But at that point, the Cambridge movement itself,
there were elements in it that wanted to strike out.
And there was efforts made to kind of contain that.
But Gloria was a little bit more radical
than most people had expected.
And she was one of those, first, she was a how it graduates.
So that was one of the connections that she had with Nag.
And so she was able to get additional nag, John Patisse,
from how it actually goes up.
And Reginald Robinson is in Cambridge, Maryland.
And then it got to the point where Robert F. Kennedy
wanted to intercede and see if he could find a remedy for Cambridge.
And so I think what he ended up doing
was extending the martial law.
It stayed in place for a little over a year in Cambridge.
And they began to have some dialogues
between the community about desegregation of Cambridge.
So doing that that spring is when Wallace came to Cambridge.
And the National Guard had this tear gas.
I don't know if they had some kind of combination mixture
of tear gas and some elements of chemicals
that actually made you nauseate it.
And so we had all these things going on at the same time.
Cliff Vaughs's one of the photographers for SNCC
was actually arrested.
And some way he was hit with a bayonet
through the calf of his legs.
So it was a very scary night when the tear gas was used.
You had these young national guards men out there.
And they just kind of the police brutality kind of thing
and throwing everybody in the truck.
And we were all arrested.
And that kind of thing.
And we ended up going to the stock A, as I said, and were released.
The general in charge of that operation,
and I think it was named was Gelson.
And he was trying to negotiate this stuff.
And he's an army general.
He's trying to be a police chief.
And so it got real confusing and complex.
At that point, that's what I think Robert F. Kennedy
interceded.
Now what we were trying to do is we were trying
to have a march from the black section of Cambridge
over to the, I think he was at the National Guard Army,
where George C. Wallace was speaking.
And that's how this whole thing kind of got out of whack
over there.
I left Cambridge, went back to how it
tried to finish up my semester and prepare
to go to Mississippi for that summer.
Because we were not only trying to recruit
student activists to go to Mississippi,
we also trying to get automobiles and other resources
that we would take to Mississippi.
So I think we ended up having two or three calls donated,
all of which we drove out.
And then in June, we drove out to Ohio for the orientation.
Freedom Summer was a project in Smith and Copa
Council of Federal, right in organizations initiated,
in part because the federal government
was not paying attention to all the abuses in Mississippi.
And the idea was that by inviting upwards
of the thousand volunteers to spend their summers in Mississippi,
it would shine the spotlight on the state
and force the federal government to do something,
among other things.
Freedom Summer became international news
when three civil rights workers Andrew Goodman, Michael
Michael "Mickey" Schwerner and James Chaney were abducted and killed by the clan.
What most people think is then the FBI came in,
and all you hear about is the FBI.
But it was very interesting that you and other people
who had just come to Mississippi were out looking for them.
They had disappeared.
The bodies would not be found for months.
Talk about going into Mississippi and who was there
and how you went about looking.
Well, when we get out to Ohio, Miami,
University at Ohio, at the Anno-Hail,
we had the orientation session set up.
And we were going through the orientation sessions.
And then we got some information that a church had been
burned to the ground in Philadelphia.
And so Michael Michael "Mickey" Schwerner and Michael Mickey Michael "Mickey" Schwerner
and Chaney and they had to pick someone a volunteer to go along with them.
And they wanted to pick a volunteer to go along with them.
And so they got Goodman as a volunteer who volunteered to go.
And they were going to go back and investigate the church burning.
And so they left.
And we actually saw him off.
And they were gone and they went back to Meridian.
They checked in.
They went straight from Meridian, all to Philadelphia.
And they didn't return to Philadelphia.
So we got in a lurch that they were missing.
And so we gave it about maybe 12 or 24 hours.
And then that's when I think many of us
knew that they didn't respond to any of the security messages and all.
That's something deadly probably had happened to them.
Bob Assemble, Bob Moses Assemble, all of the folk there.
And he said, I have you here because I want to let you know the three of our volunteers
who were here yesterday have been missing.
And that he had concluded as many of the other seasoned veterans that they were dead.
And that many people sitting in the room had a choice, a decision to make.
And that is whether or not they still wanted to go to Mississippi,
in spite of the fact that there are three people who were like you that already did.
And at that point, he said that he was still going.
And he hoped that everybody else would go.
And at that point, there was a real quiet in the room.
And I think that Jean Wheeler actually gets up and says,
starts singing a song.
And everybody kind of march out.
Well, when everybody marches out, a collective of us get together with Bob.
And we say that we are going to go in the Philadelphia.
And we can see what may have happened.
And so that consisted of, I think it was Ralph Ralph Featherstone and Dona Richards,
Bob Moses' wife at that time, Gwen Robinson, I think was her name.
Stokely Carmichael, Charlie Cobb.
I think it was Ralph Ralph Featherstone and myself.
We got in full different cars.
And we said that we would end a estate from full different directions.
Stokely Carmichael and Charlie, when one guy came in through Arkansas,
there was another group that came in through Alabama.
We came in through Northern Mississippi, down the Mississippi.
Trace, I think that's what it's called.
And there was another group that came in through Memphis.
And then we would all meet in Meridian.
And once we got in Meridian, we'd get together.
And there would be some farmers who would go out during the day
to see if they could find places that bodies would be hidden.
All where hostages might have been hill.
And they would-
Feel that about some hope, did you?
Well, you always have that in the back of your mind.
But in reality, we were thinking about bodies
that we may find more than we were hostages.
And so we all left Meridian and drove up the Philadelphia at night.
And during the day, we would be up in the loft of the barn.
And at night, somebody would come by in a truck
and it'd take us out and it'd give us a map.
And we'd go out into the valleys and into old houses
and all that kind of stuff and see if there was any signs
that hostages were held there, any of that kind of thing.
We had no lights.
We couldn't wear but belts because the buckles were glare
and there were fire towers all over across the south.
That was one of the safety things that was set up
so that people go up tall and they could look out over the flat land
and they could see where there was any smoke or fire
and they could get to it quickly.
So we had to be very concerned about those kinds of things.
And after a certain period of time, we would come back
maybe three hours, something like that.
They would come back and pick us up.
We'd go back to the house and we'd sleep until
and kind of stir around but we couldn't
that people know that we were there.
How many nights were you doing there?
We did that for, I think it was two nights we were out there.
And then we had a discussion.
We used to have discussions all the time
about what we were doing and our commitment to the movement
and our friends and how we felt like they were really a part of us.
Kind of comrades in arms.
And so we began to feel as if we were being compromised
in terms of our being out there.
And we didn't want to have the pressure come on,
the farmers who were going out looking and transporting us
and the people at where we were staying.
So we pulled a plug on it after the second night
and said we were going back to Meridian.
And then we would all be dispersed
to our respected project areas.
And I fell the stone and I went to Holly Springs.
So you tell us about Holly Springs.
What kind of a place was it?
What did you find there?
Holly Springs was a community
in which there were two colleges, two HBCUs.
One was in decline and the other one is still very vibrant
and still there now.
We found a community that had a lot of hope in that community.
You found that among many of the people who were there.
There had been some other folk in Holly Springs
before we got there.
I think what's his name?
Leslie McLemore actually graduated from Rust.
Graduated from Rust, yeah.
And so there had been some other organizers
in Holly Springs before we actually got there.
But because we had the largest project
and I'm talking about, we took in,
I think it was five or six counties,
including Oxford, which was Fayette County
and Marshall County and many of the other counties
in Union County in that area.
That we probably had one of the larger staffs there.
And it must have been about 12 or 13.
We had three master school teachers
out of Boston.
We had a nurse.
So we could do clinical work and prevention.
We could actually go out and have her examined people sometimes
who may not have been able to access a doctor
and that kind of thing.
And we were able to establish a freedom school.
We operated a community center
and had activities in for the young people.
And we actually solicited the largest number of application
for the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
And we also represented the, in larger proportion
because we had more delegates
that went to the state convention and later
to Atlantic City.
But that was what the project was like.
We had an editor from the Cremson,
who Peter, yes.
Who was Peter Cummings, I think, was his name.
And we had a little news letter that we put together.
We kept meticulous records of our work there
in out of Holly Springs.
What was the project director?
Project director was started out being Ivanhoe Donaldson.
I took over as project director and was a official project director.
I was in the fall.
From you.
Yeah.
Ivanhoe Donaldson left after the summer.
And so I took over after the summer and was project director.
What sort of reaction did you get
for the white community for this invasion of all these outside edges?
Well, Holly Springs was in the north
and it was more moderate in Holly Springs
that it was in other places.
No, in Delphis.
It was not a Delta.
It was a certain one in Southwest.
Southwest is just clandestine groups and shootings
and arbitrary killings and that kind of thing were common.
We did have fire bombings and school burnings
and church burnings and all that kind of thing.
But generally not the kind of individual people
getting killed at night, lynched in those kinds of things.
Those things did not happen.
We did have freedom days in which we actually took people down
and their names ended up in the newspaper.
And they probably lost their registered vote.
Registered vote.
And we went along without people though.
Every time they went down to make sure the things were handled very well.
You want to get registered that summer?
We had a couple of people that got registered, not very many.
It's just one go work, one go happen.
But we did have a number of freedom days
in which people were actually taken down.
They just didn't register them.
But we had a tremendous success in getting young people involved
and engaged.
We had a number of students that we sent off to college
at the end of 1965.
We had colleges that were willing to accept students
if we refer to them to them.
Roy DeBerry was one of those students
who ended up being a council member down in Jackson.
Fall on through the time.
He was a young kid when we came along.
And we kept providing the kind of nurturing and education
that we thought he needed.
And he turned out to be quite a success.
We had a local project director shortly after I left.
And that was Rita and her husband.
And in Holly Springs, there were locals.
They started out when we started out
at the beginning of the summer.
And Rita became an excellent organizer and community leader.
She died.
And her husband took over for a couple of minutes
and stayed around for a period of time.
We saw our job as going into communities
and actually organizing those communities
so that the leadership for giving direction to and organizing
would be tearing over to the local people.
We were trying to work our way out of a job.
So I never felt bad about leaving when I did,
because I knew Rita was very much capable and very competent
to run that.
Holly Springs became a fairly progressive city
in that they were able to elect the black mayor in the 90s.
And they were able to work out a kind of coexistence
with the sheriff and the police chief in that city.
I understand the police chief has just a bevy of film
photos from that summer, because he was,
but he won't release them.
He won't.
He's shown to some people who go down and ask about them,
but I understand he has a treasure trove full of records
that I can do.
Right.
And we have had several reunions, the group from Holly Springs.
And we have a large number of volunteers who come back.
We had collected all the material that we had on that notes
and newsletters and all that kind of thing.
And we put that, we archived that at Russ College.
So those records are there with photographs
and all that, including the reunions.
And so Larry Rubin was one of the people in that project there.
And we had a number of people.
The attorney for President Clinton on the,
on the, what did they call them?
They were going, D, what were they going to do with Clinton?
They were going to take him out of office.
Oh, go.
We can teach.
And Peach, the one that was his private attorney
was on the project there in Holly Springs.
So we just chat about those kinds of things
throughout the years about the various and secondary experience.
Holly Fry was also a producer, one of the documentary
zone, Mississippi at Summer.
He and Connie Field and a couple of others did the movie.
Where do we go from here?
Freedom on my mind.
Yes.
And so we've had a lot of very positive things
come out of that experience in Holly Springs.
You mentioned the organizing of the Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party.
The idea was to get a representation,
to go to Atlantic City, to challenge the legitimacy
of the seating of the all white segregationist party.
Blacks were not permitted to participate in that.
Talk a little bit about Atlantic City in your time.
You're there and your reactions to everything.
OK.
The Atlantic City experience was very interesting
because we managed to box up all of the applications
that we have received.
We actually had what we call Watts logs
on the experiences of that summer, where we kind of documented
every event that went on.
We even documented the fact that the Democratic Party
in the state of Mississippi was not loyal.
It didn't vote for the Democratic Party ticket
in presidential election in 1960.
They didn't just deny blacks an opportunity
to come to the pre-sanked meetings and all that.
They usually shifted it away.
They wouldn't tell you where they were being held
in some instances.
And so they were not just discriminatory.
They just outright said, no, blacks would not be in that.
The idea was to follow the procedures of the Democratic Party
and electing delegates to represent the state of Mississippi
going forward.
And what we were able to do is we were able to document
that we followed that procession.
The pre-sanked meetings, the district meetings,
the state meeting, and the election of delegations,
open elections, democratic process, the state chose not
to use that and made it very clear that they were not going
to use that.
I had the pleasure, I guess, of taking the bell off
of the church in Philadelphia that was burned.
We put that on top of the truck.
And we had the burnout station wagon on the back of the truck.
So we took every visual.
We were able to get the station wagon from the airport.
We were able to get to station wagon.
We put it on the back of the truck.
And we took both of those things up.
And we had that on display so people could actually see it.
And we had a caption on the bottom of it
and what that actually was.
Which car was station wagon?
This was the station wagon that Goodman, Sherry, and Cheney
were in when they were arrested and later murdered
in Philadelphia, Mississippi.
And what happened was they took the station wagon out
the sheriff and the deputies and the rest of the folk
took it out to kind of a dirt road.
And they burned it up.
And that's what we had.
So we wanted to let people see the level of violence
and destruction that people were willing to result to in order
to maintain the system of segregation.
And we all set those things up so people could see.
And we kind of followed the delegation around in order
to make sure that they could maneuver through whatever
they needed to maneuver through.
They would be at the right place at the right time.
And what we discovered was initially, as the delegates
moved around other delegates, they
seemed to get a lot of support.
And then I think the issue became,
it began to look like for the Democratic party that it was
going to be an issue of much larger than what they expected.
So the Johnson administration decided
that they needed to have a person in charge of making sure
that the convention would not be disrupted
and against the president.
And so he delegated that responsibility
to the human humphory, who then delegated it to Walter Mondale.
And they decided that they needed to be a compromise,
because the delegates from the Mississippi
and Democratic party was asking to be seated in place of and
replacing.
And they were building that on a moral case.
They were committed to Democratic party.
They were not discriminatory.
They had a diverse delegation that was there.
And they wanted to be considered citizens like everybody
else.
The issue that they were willing to push for
is the right to vote for everybody.
And that they figured that if they had gotten the right to vote,
that they probably would have been in the ranks of the Democratic
party.
So they were loyal in that sense.
And when the got time to decide on what was going to happen
with those issues, the Walter Mondale and Humphory came up with the idea
that they would be granted two seats at large.
And those with, I think, the majority of the Connecticut
delegation, they had accepted the fact that they would be there.
And they came back to the delegation to say that this is what we
are prepared to give.
And at that point, the delegation was to meet.
But before they met, they had this bevy of coalition
folk from the Marjorne Washington,
speak to the delegation to try to convince them that that was, in fact, a victory.
Dr. King and Whitney Young, and somebody from, I can't remember all the names of the
people.
And 19 or 20 people that spoke in a church before this delegation.
But when Johnson actually, President Johnson actually found out that this was going to be
a serious offense, is when Fannie Lou Hamer spoke.
And she was about to speak on national TV.
And at that same moment, he called a press conference that took the press away from
that.
And some of the major networks decided to go ahead and run that tape late on that night.
Because President Johnson didn't have anything to talk about at that particular press conference.
And that's the speech where Fannie Lou Hamer said, I question America.
If you don't, you know, seek this democratically elected and selected delegation, where are
we in America?
And after the meeting and all that kind of stuff, all of the, I guess, labor, liberal kind
of folk left, the delegation was sitting there and they had to decide whether or not they
were going to accept the compromise.
And after meeting, I think it was Fannie Lou Hamer who said that, you know, we've worked
too hard and we've come too far to accept that compromise.
And we came here to be seated and we're not going to be seated.
And we'll go home and start over again and continue this process to see if we can get
the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party represented in the Democratic Party as the legitimate
entity in the party.
But you all feel after that you've gone up there, you have been given a compromise that
wasn't acceptable.
It was liberal friends in the North and not accommodating.
Oh no.
We were very proud about the position taken by the Mississippi delegation, Mississippi Freedom
Democratic Party delegation.
But we devastated about the fact that inside of the Democratic Party, morality wasn't
the basis upon which decisions are made.
It's power politics at its voice.
And we hadn't.
We've still very idealistic about, you know, if we do the right things and if we follow
the procedures, then good things will happen to you.
That wasn't the case.
And so it was devastating.
And at that point, I think Folk and Snick began to put all of those elements, including
the Democratic Party to the side, and these are not going to be the vehicles that we can
ride in order to forget to freedom, justice, and equality.
And then there was the search on then for where do we go from here in terms of the transition
from the old line politics of working within the Democratic Party and working within with
these coalitions that we currently had.
And so that's when we began to look at the possibility of establishing links with other
minority groups and see if we could talk about empowerment and self-determination and those
kinds of issues where we were beginning to look at.
And we began to move outside of the mainstream of just looking within America.
We began to look at other movements that were going on in Asia and Africa and South
America and the West Indies, not the West Indies, but in the South America based in Gulf
Basin down there.
And so we began to look at what was going on in Cuba and we began to send people down
there in Russia and Asia and a number of other places where there were independent movements
and Mozambique and Guinea-Bassal and Guinea and all those places where movement was actually
going.
So SNCC is undergoing some transformation?
Going through transformation, absolutely.
And then we have the Selma campaign of 55 SNCC had been in Selma for several years.
And Martin Luther King and the Southern Christian Leadership Conference chose Selma as the spot
where they were going to stage demonstrations and push for the passes of the voting rights
law.
What did you get to Selma and what did you do there?
I was in Mississippi as we were having a state MFDP meeting there.
But before that we had had a staff meeting and the issue of Selma came up.
And most of us agreed that there was a difference in a strategic difference between SNCC and
SCLC and that is that we believed in building organization as opposed to mobilizing for some
particular objective.
And John raised the question about Selma and he said it was in Alabama and it was close
to his hometown and that he wanted to participate.
John Lewis.
Yeah.
And we took the position that John, we are not going to be engaged in the demonstration
in Selma.
But we didn't know of the strategic plan that had been put together between SCLC and Johnson
administration.
We didn't know that if that push got going that the voting rights act was going to be tied
to how effective that was.
And so we said John you cannot independently because that is what he was talking about as
chairman of SNCC be a part of this March.
And John said that he deserved the right to be able to own conscious, be able to go on
this March.
And so I think the conclusion was that John, we really don't want you to do this.
But if you do this we will have some SNCC people there with you.
So you see Bob Mance is with John on this March.
And then when John goes over the bridge, John ends up suffering a concussion and is actually
kind of airlifted out of Selma to Boston and ought to for him to get the hit checked
out for the concussion and see how severe that was.
Now anytime anybody in SNCC is ever injured or wounded or is in jail or whatever it is,
the philosophy of the organization was that we sent somebody in right away.
And so when we recall in the afternoon of Bloody Sunday, we immediately called together
some of the people who were at the assembly and found out who had vehicles who could go
and how many people were going to be in the vehicles.
And then we launched those people for Selma almost immediately.
So it was a period of private between and hour and hour and a half before people were
actually leaving that convention going to Selma.
And once we got to Selma, Jim was coming down from Atlanta.
He was flying in.
I think he got a helicopter.
Yeah, he got a helicopter.
Some kind of way he got something to fly into Selma.
And so we all got there.
We knew where we were supposed to be going.
We met there and we were told that there was nothing left to be done.
We got an update on John and we said the next day we would spread out and begin to work
through the process of what would be the next steps.
We were still kind of ambivalent about being there, but the injury that John, that has
always been an operational principle.
If one of our, among our ranks had some difficulty, we would rush in and try to provide the
kind of support and try to continue the work that they were doing until they could either
recover or we could find a replacement for that.
I took over the logistical parts and that is trying to work with Hosea Williams and the other logistical
people in the SCLC where the march was to go.
And we also brought in Willie "Mukasa" Ricks who could mobilize the young people.
And so we wanted to keep the pressure on now.
If we hadn't used all of our resources to build up support for the march, we would.
And then we had that issue with the injunction to march the injunction from Johnson.
I think it was federal judge.
And the question was whether or not Dr. King was going to violate that injunction.
And I think he concluded that he was going to violate that injunction.
But when he marched, he marched across the bridge and then turned around and came back
to the church.
And that kind of threw everybody off.
And to be honest with you, it pissed most of the SNCC off because nobody told us what
the plan was.
And here we are operating and we don't have a sense of plan.
So at this point, Jim decides to go down to Montgomery and start another set of demonstrations
in Montgomery.
And kind of make sure that we understand that there's a connection between that.
But we'll do that in Montgomery and create the kind of protest down in Montgomery.
And that started.
And we begin to try to work out and try to find out what is going on here.
And why is it that we are not informed about the objectives?
And so we kind of worked through that.
And we got a time and a date that we were actually start out of Selma.
And we worked logistics out to get the march all the way into Montgomery.
There is a point in which Jim and some other folks in Montgomery, this is the leadership
group.
And Jim is talking about knocking the legs out from under the table if everybody can't
be equal around that table.
And I think that it became very clear that there was some missing information and links
that we didn't have.
But we figured that once the march got into Selma, that would be over with and we would
move on.
And we did not know about Johnson's speech after that about the Voting Rights Act.
And we shall overcome and then later the passage of the Voting Rights Act.
So that was kind of tense in there.
But it wasn't tense because we didn't like people.
It was tense because we were on different pages about where we were in terms of protests.
And we had been in Selma for two years prior to SCLC coming in there.
And we knew that a march would only last maybe 30 days after the march had concluded.
And that people would dissipate because you haven't organized them into anything.
And that was our real concern.
We were trying to build in Selma.
And we stayed there and we continued and we did build a little something in Selma.
And that was because we went to the next plan and that is building independent political
organizations.
We talked a little bit about Lowndes County, Alabama and how that represented a change for SNCC.
Right.
I don't care more about Lounge.
One of the effects of the Selma march was that Stokely Carmichael Carmichael and others went through
Lowndes County, Alabama.
And they started organizing people there.
And the result was a project for SNCC after that where a number of SNCC field secretaries
were leaving Mississippi and other projects because they saw something different happening
there.
Tell me a little bit about Lowndes County, Alabama in your experience.
Okay.
We did go through Lowndes County, Alabama and everywhere we knew that we had to do something a little
different in terms of a march and not have just a group of people marching down a highway
that we had to get people along the highway to at least get involved in and actually understand
what is going on.
So it was a fertile area.
It was a part of the Black Belt in Alabama.
Stokely Carmichael was pretty disenchanted as many of us were with the response that we received
from the Democratic Party with the challenge.
And we're looking for other ways in which we could actually organize political power.
We call it individual, I mean independent political organizing.
And we were looking at Lowndes County, Alabama, Alabama.
But we had a pretty healthy and sturdy research department back in Atlanta.
And Jack Minnis actually goes through the laws in Alabama and he finds that you can
actually organize an independent party in a particular county in Alabama.
This was a part of law that was passed during the Civil War era.
And it said that we could actually go in and organize a separate party in the state of
Alabama in any county.
But there were certain requirements that you must go through.
So we used that to begin to look at organizing in Lowndes County, Alabama and Dallas County and Green
County.
And there's another county in Alabama.
I can't remember what the name of that one is.
And we started out with Lowndes County, Alabama.
Now at that point, Snick didn't have the kind of resources it had for 1964.
The resources have already began to decline.
And so the job and the task for making resources available fell on me.
And so what I did was I got other Snickers to go into Lowndes County, Alabama to work along with
Stokely Carmichael and into other counties.
And the majority of those folks were the nagged people who had come down the summer of
1964 who were still working, some in Mississippi and some in other places.
And we put those in.
And we got some out of Georgia, Southwest Georgia, to move into that area.
Because we didn't have a lot of people who transferred in from Mississippi that there.
Those people that left out of Mississippi generally went home or went on some of the mission.
But we were also trying to pay down the organization because after the summer of 1964, Snick ended
up taking in about 70 to 80 of those volunteers.
And there were a couple of dynamic changes that took place in Snick.
One was that we got up to a membership that was over 100.
And we also went from being a predominantly black organization to a predominantly white
organization.
And that created some ideological and philosophical concerns in the organization also.
But what happens is that the stepping up and the escalation of the anti-war movement
drain off a lot of those folks who were in Snick because that became the exciting kind
of interface kind of mobilizing that many people began to shift off to.
But it was Jack who came up with the idea and the plan.
And we took that plan and went to Lowndes County, Alabama, to Lowndes County, Alabama and organized what was
called the Lowndes County, Alabama Freedom Organization.
Same kind of acronym, same kind of freedom that we were talking about.
But we were talking about empowerment now.
That was one of the things that came out of Mississippi that people wanted to empower
themselves.
And we thought that this was one of the ways in which we could actually do that.
We were trying to create a new model, another model that could be employed and taken outside
Lowndes County, Alabama to urban areas and wherever else we were to find those pockets where African
Americans were the majority and see if we could use that to leverage coalition politics
with a kind of sound, solid foundation in the African American community.
So we used limited resources and they began to organize the Lowndes County, Alabama organization
and the Democratic Party found out what was going on.
And I think that that influence on the media at that point made people begin to refer
to the Lowndes County, Alabama Freedom Organization as the Black Panther Party.
And so that was supposed to be a negative and everybody was supposed to say, oh, this
is not going to work.
But for the African American community, that was a very positive kind of thing.
And so we would, during the period where there were going to be elections and we had organized
campaigns and actually got people on the ballot and they were running for elections,
we solicited young men from Philadelphia and Chicago and New York and California to come
down just to be pole watches and help drive people around and do those kinds of things.
And so the, many of them came down and when they went back to those respective communities,
they considered themselves to be the friends of the Black Panther Party.
And so this is how the notion of Black Panther gets out to California and Chicago and
in New York.
And all over these areas, you can find that some kind of organization that's supposed
to be Black Panthers were created.
So it's not a, it's not a strain for us to understand that Bobby Sears and Bobby Sears
was not admitted.
Use the Lowndes County, Alabama model as the kind of model that they were going to employ in California
and Oakland to actually empower that particular community and then spread out with the Black
Panther Party is going in other directions.
Basically own kind of, it's a standard traditional politics.
So you were organizing there and elections were held and although blacks were in a majority,
they did not win.
What went on with the elections?
I think that we didn't have the confidence in all of the people in Lowndes County, Alabama to go
out and vote.
The next election that was held, they won most of the offices.
So it was just a matter of going through it the first time around, but you can explain
that the people who they can actually see.
One of the things that we always did was SNCC as an organization provided information.
So we put together these little booklets that people could actually see with Black people
on the cover in that precinct, Lowndes County, Alabama.
And we also talked about the role and responsibility for the sheriff, the qualification for a sheriff.
So that people would feel confident that if they had those very simple qualifications
that they could be a candidate for that particular office.
And so it was a defeat because we were just getting people acclimated to the idea of empowerment
and the importance of the vote and actually in lockstep.
I think we find that that kind of apprehension was eliminated through these kind of efforts
back here when you have the 2008 and the 2012 elections with African American vote.
Because people assume that they was going to still be that kind of apprehension and they
weren't coming out to vote.
And I just observed in the 2012 that people, even people who were considered to be those
will never vote because they have some kind of dereliction or they had some kind of
issue.
And they would take that day off.
It would almost be like the birthday.
They'd be straight and they'd be in that line.
And because Obama said to stay until you read to your vote, they were willing to do that.
All the agitation said, don't go for the okie doke.
Don't get out of line.
Stay there to your vote.
Then after you vote, you're on your own.
But I think what I'm saying is that, yeah, the first time around, that wasn't successful.
The second time around, they actually won office and the school board and the city council
and later mayor, Lowns.
I can't think of the name of the town in Lowns County.
But one of the cities in Lowns elected a black mayor and so you began to see that shift
take place.
Again, by this time there's an upheaval in, in, in, well, let me just take that one back.
I'm, I'm thinking too far in advance.
But what I am, what I'm going is is that while the, the, the election is, is coming back
around and they're organizing is still going on in, in Alabama.
One of the things that happens is that, Samuel Younge Jr is killed in, in January 1966 and,
um, uh, the SNCC responds by putting out a statement against the war in Vietnam.
And so you began to see that whole notion that I talked about earlier about tying in to,
becoming more international and tying in to groups that are working on self determination.
And we see some of that as some of what, what it is that we are trying to, to do and, and
the community, which we're working.
We can move here to, uh, and we've taken too much of your time so we're going to wrap
this up soon.
But I would like for you to talk about it as you've written about.
SNCC is undergoing all kinds of changes in, like 1967, it's in a real process.
When you talk about that and, and your observations as a, as a member of the group.
Well, there's several things happen.
One is is that, uh, we had been successful, clearly.
And success has a tendency to make people move on.
Uh, and I'm talking about successful in terms of the 1964 Civil Rights Bill, the 1965
Voting Rights Bill, widespread desegregation.
You're talking about, um, the, uh, widespread participation in the, in the voting process,
registering to vote, numbers of people coming out, impoliments of groups that were marginalized
for a long period of time.
So these, these are kind of victories that you, that you have to recognize that are taking
place.
You can go all the way back through that period with, with the long view of the, of the
movement and see a number of victories if you put, if you, if you use that perspective.
Um, the other thing is, is that working in areas like Mississippi and Alabama, where you
do have the, the shooting in, in, in Lowndes County, Alabama and, um, uh, Rev. James Reeb is, is, uh,
is kill the seminarian and the other, uh, Catholic, uh, priest is wounded.
Um, that you can do about two years and after two years, you probably need to, uh, retool
and, and remove the tapes and all that kind of stuff because you just can't do it.
It's too much.
It's, it's too much of an emotional kind of, of, uh, stream that, that's not, not good
for the, for the, uh, for, for you, for the individual.
Um, and you began to see other kinds of things happening.
One is, is that you began to see the emphasis shift away from, um, um, from civil rights
to the anti-war movement for many young white students.
And so there's a shifting away there.
Uh, you also began to see the whole notion about, uh, empowerment, black power, uh, coming
on.
And the perception is in how black power is actually projected, comes from a position
paper of the Atlanta project.
It was never officially voted on by SNCC.
It was not the position paper on, um, on black power from SNCC.
And what happens in that position paper is, as a very narrow view about a kind of black
white kind of, uh, analysis.
And, you know, blacks, whites feels superior to blacks and blacks now should put white
side organization, all that kind of stuff.
That was never, uh, the basis upon which a black power was brought into, to view.
Because our assessment and analysis was much larger than just a color, skin color kind
of analysis.
And we, we fought that argument, we fought that argument in SNCC, but, uh, the, the, the
status quo, uh, bought into another idea.
So many young people were, were moving away.
Um, we didn't have, newer people coming in, newer people coming in, we didn't have a
way to educate, uh, those newer people about, even the most recent history.
So people were coming in, they didn't know anything about the freedom riders in, bail,
no, um, bail, uh, jail, no bail.
And, and that whole history and that experience.
So you had new people coming in and it was just extremely difficult for the organization
to move forward.
Plus, we, we, you know, I hear a lot of people that underestimate the impact of co-intail
probe.
Co-intail probe had a massive effect in impact on people.
I ended up in, in prison for three months, uh, during the summer of 1967.
For, for nothing other than the fact that the judge said that I had, I, I, I was a
risk and that they were going to deny me bail until Justice Black at the Supreme Court
said, you got to get them gone.
This is on my, uh, induction into the military and being found guilty.
Even though there was never a case and I have never been retried over that case, they
held me in prison for three months that I don't get any credit for anywhere.
So those things were real and, and the disruption of families and the, uh, credibility,
and the character assassination and all that was, was going on.
So these are the things that I think caused, uh, somewhat of the demise of the movement.
It was never a black power.
It was never a conflict between SNCC and, and, and Dr. King.
And, you know, I was, and, and this is where I want to at least say this and we go write
it and we go and document it and all.
But when (David) Garrow did his book back on King, uh, he came and he ended up in prison for a
time and he came and he interviewed me and I said, (David) Garrow, I want to tell you something
that happened, uh, shortly after Cicero, Illinois, Dr. King came back to Atlanta.
I, I went back to Atlanta.
Dr. King asked, Stokeley, Rick's and myself to come by the house.
He wanted to just have us over for dinner and he had us down in the basement.
And we stayed there for maybe four or five hours and he said, I want to understand black
power.
I want to understand what you're saying about black power.
And we went through that and we went through the history and he said, but what about
this and what about that?
He asked all the questions that he wanted to have answered and he says that, okay, I am
not going to be a, as an organizational person, we are not going to be able to endorse and
support black power, okay?
We just can't do that.
And we said, okay, but because you can't, then we have to agree that neither of us will
find ourselves in a situation where we condemn one another and we're going to all be able
to go down the same street and we'll all be very supportive.
And we kind of shook hands on that because he said, now explain to me where you're coming
from and what you're saying and is this just a hatred of whites and all that kind of
stuff we explain that we're not even talking about that.
We're talking about empowerment of black tying our movement to movements outside and all
that kind of stuff and that's where we come from.
You know our history, you know how we have gone through this experience.
And I think in the, from chaos to community, Dr. Kang says that there were some people
who articulated black power that were okay, but there were others who got it all screwed
up.
And I think that that is the time when he makes a reference to this meeting in our agreement
because there was never a moment in which there was a antagonism between Stokely Carmichael and Dr.
Kang.
Matter of fact, when Dr. Kang came out in 67 with his position against the war in Vietnam,
he called and asked Stokely Carmichael and I to come to that Sunday morning meeting and Stokely Carmichael
said, but you know I'm a heathen.
He said, bring your butt on anyhow because I have something I want to say and we got
there.
We want the front.
Oh yeah.
So I'm there and I'm listening and he goes, you know, and I said, and that's what we asked
you to do all the time.
You know we kept telling you that there was a moral basis.
I was more political and we understand, you know, but you have to deal with that on a
moral basis.
So that is missed sometimes and you know and people keep the myth going about these other
kinds of things.
Now, (David) Garrow said that he couldn't find among other lieutenants of Dr. Kang a confirmation
of that meeting.
I said, I guess he thought I made it up, but I think that's pivocal.
You know, it's a fascinating piece of theory.
And you know, I talked to Willa Rick all the time.
I talked to Kwame about that before he died and I said, you know, that's that's the
part of the history we need to make sure is kept.
But if you read Kwame's autobiography, you know, he actually talks about the friendship
and the finance.
When Dr. Kang goes to what is Resurrection City, was it Resurrection City?
I was after he was in Washington, I think, setting up for that kind of thing.
And he was having problems with the black militants up there.
And he said, it's the Stokely Carmichael, I need some help with this.
And he said, what you need?
And he said, I need for these people to back off a few minutes.
Because what's happening is they're creating so much conflict that I can't give a message
out about poverty.
And so he said, okay, and he went around and he talked to all those groups, called them
all again and said, if you all don't want to be in bomb with this program to Dr. Kang,
then don't go.
But leave him alone.
And so they still had that kind of working relationship, even as we were moving closer
to Memphis and his assassination.
Wow, this is all about fascinating stuff.
I think we're going to have to come back.
If you are willing.
What we have here is a period when you personally were undergoing much stress with the being
jailed for refusing the draft, the organizing at Orangeburg, the Orangeburg massacre,
where you were incarcerated there, you were broke.
You had limited resources and yet you came back and you devoted yourself to career and
education.
You got your master's in Harvard, your doctorate at UNC.
Tell us briefly what you've been doing these last 40 years.
Well, what I've been doing these last 40 years is enjoying one of the most unique experiences
that I've ever had.
And that was being a member of a situation that was almost like a university setting where
I had contact with the Archibald coxies of the world, and Dr. Kang and Whitney Youngs
and Malcolm X and Ella Baker and Fandall Hamlin and Ruby Dyer's Robinson and a collective
of individuals who made a difference in this world.
I got an education that I could not have gotten under any other circumstance.
And so I'm trying to share that with the community from which I have come and share that with
the community that's still interested in knowing about the courage and determination of these
legends.
I stand on the show of them.
I'm very proud of them.
I want to represent them.
I want to be able to tell my story and tell their story too.
As in telling my always include them in that whole process.
Part of your story is your autobiography.
The copy is right there.
People that up, the river of no return.
It was published 40 years ago.
And I still think that it is in terms of movement autobiographies.
This is the most insightful and honest I have read.
So people watching this are reading the transcript.
Pick up this book.
And you will get even more of the story.
Dr. Seller, thank you very much.
We are indebted to you for sharing your insights with us.
OK.
Thank you very much.
And I'm glad to be able to get the latter part into this film.
Yeah.
I know that.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.